k
[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live Boa
noite Evanete Isaac
Alexandre Alice Vogel Cristina sejam
todos muito
bem-vindos bem temos algumas perguntas
aqui
para
responder vou dividir a tela com vocês
me digam se tá legível Tá eu vou tentar
aumentar o máximo possível aqui o
tamanho eu acho que tá legível aqui
Boa noite também huberg me deem por
favor o feedback do áudio e também se
vocês estão conseguindo ler as perguntas
aí da
tela Evanete Isaac Alexandre Alice
Vogel Cristina e ruberg vocês que estão
ao vivo por favor me digam se o áudio tá
passando legal e se vocês estão
conseguindo ler
Evanete já deu um feedback aqui que o
som Está ok legal bem a primeira
pergunta é doutor qual seria a Dose
Certa do nac NS sisina pra pessoa
alcoólatra Pera aí que deixa eu fazer
uma coisa diferente
aqui só um minutinho pessoal que eu vou
mudar aqui
Peraí deixa eu ver se tá mudando aqui
não não tá não legal eu não queria que
mudasse aqui
28 Ah tá agora eu entendi o que tá
acontecendo
aqui me deem só um
instante eu acho que eu tô lendo a
segunda pergunta
deixa eu ver se é isso mesmo que eu
tinha visto uma pergunta da Maria
Helena mas eu não sei porque não tá
aqui Maria Helena você tá aí ao vivo tá
Vou vou pular essas perguntas da Maria
Helena que eu acho que talvez tenha sido
da semana passada eu tô me confundindo
aqui creio que seja isso mesmo e vou
partir pra pergunta da ivanet ou ivanet
agora não lembro que
ivanet tá ao vivo Tá sim Ivanete Me
confirma ser é homem ou mulher desculpa
eu eu não
lembro vamos lá então qual que seria a
Dose Certa do nac ou NSA para pessoas
alcoólatras que que é o na nac é um
aminoácido que faz parte da glutationa n
a glutationa ela é composta por três
aminoácidos né a acetilcisteína a
glicina e o ácido glutâmico então ele
atua como antioxidante porque é o
aminoácido mais importante para formar
glutationa então pessoas que TM problema
com álcool o nac vai ajudar bastante a
proteger o fígado contra os danos
causados por esse agente
a dose pode variar de 600 MG a 10000
MG geralmente você divide em duas doses
manhã e noite a dose vai depender peso
da saúde do fígado e o tempo que a
pessoa consome o álcool se a pessoa
tiver danos muito importantes ao fígado
muitos profissionais sugerem começar com
doses mais baixas 300 mg duas vezes ao
dia e ajustando a dose conforme a
resposta e a muito importante você
associar o na é uma dieta rica em
antioxidantes evitar o álcool se a
pessoa for o alcoólatra então muitas
vezes vai ter que fazer uma um
tratamento né com substâncias para ser
livrar do álcool uma opção é naltrexona
de alta
dosagem também suplementos como Complexo
B zinco e Cardo Mariana silimarina vão
ajudar no tratamento vão ajudar na
desintoxicação e Regeneração hepática
Ok próxima pergunta o citrato de
clomifeno clomide é uma abordagem
interessante pergunta do blanders e o
senhor usa em seus pacientes para
estimular a produção de testosterona em
homens adultos com sintomas e
dosagens E baixa testosterona seria uma
alternativa antes de ir para a TRT que é
a terapia de repulsão de
testosterona Obrigado Evanete é feminino
Obrigado por
responder a Maria Lena tá respondendo
aqui que não tem Pergunta hoje então as
perguntas que eu tava vendo era da
semana passada bem Vamos responder essa
pergunta do clomide O clomide que é o
clomifeno eu uso bastante aqui no
consultório É uma opção interessante
para estimular a produção natural de
testosterona em homens adultos que T um
sintomas de hipogonadismo né ou seja
níveis baixos de testosterona como é que
usa como é que age o clomide ou
clomifeno ele age no cérebro ele é um
cerm que é um modulador seletivo de
receptor de estrogênio ele vai bloquear
os receptores de estrogênio no
hipotálamo no cérebro isso vai aumentar
a liberação de hormônios especialmente o
LH e o
FSH e especialmente o LH que é hormônio
leniz vai no testículo e estimula
produzir mais
testosterona se a pessoa tem ainda
reserva testicular tem muitos homens na
faixa de 50 60 anos que ainda tem
reserva testicular essa estratégia
funciona bem para aumentar a produção de
testosterona no testículo e não precisa
fazer a terapia de reposição com
testosterona Então vale a pena testar
isso aqui tentar isso antes de entrar
diretamente com a testosterona como é
que eu sei se o paciente Vai responder
ou não a clío clomifeno geralmente o LH
dele tá baixo de cinco é os casos que
tem mais indicação de usar o
clomifeno Mas mesmo que o LH tenha
esteja né entre 5 e 10 você pode tentar
utilizar em alguns casos ainda
responde as doses são baixas se você usa
de 5 10 ou 20 MG por dia para ver como é
que ele responde a testosterona
geralmente o LH vai subir no sangue e a
testosterona Vai subir junto e vários
homens respondem bem Tem aumento dos
níveis hormonais tem melhora de fadiga
melhora de libido melhora da atividade
sexual mas tem gente que mesmo com
aumento da testosterona não responde
clinicamente efeitos colaterais são
raros Mas pode acontecer oscilação de
humor alteração visual sensibilidade da
mama né que a gencom mastia se por acaso
essa testosterona
virar estradiol que acontece em
pacientes que têm muita gordura
visceral pacientes
obesos e lembrar que além do clomide do
clomifeno você pode est repondo o zinco
se tiver indicação porque o zinco é
importante para formação de testosterona
repor a vitamina D repor o magnésio
controlar o estresse crônico que
atrapalha a produção de testosterona
melhorar o sono que também atrapalha a
produção de testosterona combater
obesidade com dieta atividade física
cortar a exposição a toxinas
especialmente os derivados do Plástico e
agrotóxicos então cortar o plástico da
sua vida parar de esquentar as coisas no
micas com
plástico outros suplementos naturais
você pode utilizar a Chanda e o ksm 66
que é derivado da Chanda que aumenta a
testosterona o Tomcat al também aumenta
tem várias substâncias pode ser
utilizado né o tríos terrestres
euricom longifolia tem vários aí
né e a a musculação é muito importante
também para aumentar a testosterona
minha próxima pergunta ainda sobe os
níveis de testosterona masculina existe
exame que detecte a falha testicular sim
na baixa produção de testosterona sim
são os exames que a gente pede
normalmente para ver função hormonal né
testosterona toal e livre shbg que é a
proteína carreadora de
testosterona testosterona a gente quer
que esteja no segundo terceiro quartis
né perdão entre o terceiro e quarto
quartis é melhor né então se o máximo do
laboratório for 700 a gente quer que a
testosterona esteja por volta de 500 a
700 Ok vai depender de laboratório para
laboratório você pode pedir o LH FSH que
eu acabei de comentar né se o LH tiver
abaixo de c
a pessoa pode responder melhor ao uso do
clomifeno níveis Altos de LH sem est
usando o clomifeno sugere que a pessoa
tem hipogonadismo primário que é a falha
testicular
Ok ou seja mesmo com a hipófise
hipotálamo trabalhando o testículo não
responde então não vai produzir
testosterona esses casos você vai ter
que fazer o uso de reposição hormonal
mesmo ultrassom testículo para ver se
tem atrofia testicular
alguns casos raros você faz ressonância
de hipófise para ver se não tem algum
tumor hipofisário isso é mais
raro alguns casos pessoas jovens com
problemas sexuais você pode pedir o
cariótipo que existe uma doença genética
que chama síndrome de Clan felter eu vi
uns três casos na minha vida isso aqui
que é a pessoa que tem três cromossomos
sexuais em vez de ser XX ou XY é o
XXY responde até por 10% dos casos de
hipogonadismo primário Ou seja pessoas
que já nasceram com a testosterona baixa
como eu falei só peguei três ou quatro
casos desses na minha
vida tá então em alguns casos você pede
a prolactina também que em alguns casos
de problema de testosterona é por
excesso de prolactina por tumores
produtores desse hormônio são os
prolactinomas aí tem um remédio chamado
dostinex que trata isso daí
tá então os principais exames é
testosterona LH FSH
shbg aí você pode pedir também o
estradiol em homens que especialmente se
ele for
obesos e em casos mais raros ressonância
de crânio e exame genético
Ok próxima pergunta o que há de mais
moderno na medicina integrativa para
estímulo
natural de testosterona masculina
inibição de oromas se puder listar os
produtos su e dosagens agradecemos Ah
não tem coisa tão moderna assim
tá tem várias estratégias né principal é
sempre você priorizar a nutrição o mais
natural possível comer gorduras naturais
gorduras saudáveis que vão estimular a
produção dos hormônios que são
esteroides né que são os hormônios
sexuais são derivados do colesterol
então a alimentação com gordura saudável
vai ajudar muito a musculação que eu
acabei de comentar que ajuda aumentar os
níveis hormonais a
testosterona o sono adequado também vai
ajudar o jejum também ajuda o zinco já
comentei aqui que pessoas que TM
deficiência de zinco pode ajudar a
aumentar a testosterona a vitamina D
também já comentei manter ela em níveis
Entre 50 e 70 no sangue o magnésio
também se tiver deficiente vai
atrapalhar a testosterona você pode usar
fitoterapia né como eu já comentei aqui
Ach Ganda Tribulus terrestres feno grego
eurica longifolia e o tong Ket ali tem
um monte de coisa aí que você pode usar
para aumentar
testosterona se a pessoa tiver o
estrogênio muito alto você pode usar um
inibidor de
aromatase que tem aí as drogas no
mercado a anastrozol letrozol mas
natural tem um dinol metano ele pedi
para falar doses não dose do zinco vai
variar de acordo com a deficiência mais
entre 30 a 50 mg por dia na média a
vitamina D vai variar de 5.000 a 10.000
por dia o magnésio de 200 a 400 mg por
dia se tiver muito rápido depois você
revê o vídeo e anota tá a chaga se for a
ch Ganda comum é entre 300 e 600 MG ao
dia se for o ksm vai ser uns 150 200 mg
por dia o tribulus é de 250 a 500 mg por
dia o feno grego é de 500 mg por dia o
de indol metano que vai inibir aromatase
entre 100 a 200 mg por
dia
Resveratrol também ajuda pessoas que TM
aí problema de metabolismo estrogênio
você pode usar de 150 a 300 mg por dia a
crisina que tem o inhibidor de aromatase
É meio caro Eu geralmente uso mais
transdérmico na pele por volta de 100 mg
Mas você pode estar usando oral entre
500 a 1000 mg por o
dia tá bom então é
isso próxima
pergunta também no
blanders Existe algum mecanismo
fisiológico do corpo que regule a
testosterona abaixar por alguma doença
essa pergunta ficou um pouco confusa o
organismo Ele regula a testosterona
através do LH que é produzido na hipó
e a próprio LH ele é regulado pelo gnrh
que é
o gonot tropin releasing hormone que é
da do hipotálamo tá não sei se ISO você
tá perguntando então tem esse eixo
hipotálamo hipófise gonadal começa no
gen RH gon tropin release hormon que
estimula o hipófise a produzir LH FSH e
LH atua na célula de li do testículo
aumentando a produção de testosterona tá
não sei se a tá querendo perguntar o que
que interfere nisso de doença obesidade
sinom metabólica que é o pessoal que tem
glicose alta triglicérides alto
circunferência abdominal grande pessoas
obesas pessoas tem pressão alta eh vai
acontecer muito aromatização da
testosterona estradiol estrógeno e
resistência insulínica que vai
atrapalhar essas duas coisas vai
atrapalhar a ação da testosterona várias
doenças inflamatórias doenças crônicas
como insuficiência renal insuficiência
hepática Artrite reumatoide vai
atrapalhar a testosterona então é muito
abrangente tá o hipotiroidismo também
atrapalha a testosterona pessoas
hipotiroid tem menos ação da
testosterona pessoas que TM cortisol
muito alto né estressado o cortisol
atrapalha a ação da
testosterona tá então novamente mudança
estilo de vida vai ajudar na
testosterona Quais são os três
principais fatos aí da mudança de estilo
de vida
jejum aumento da
gordura saudável e corte das substâncias
artificiais alimentos processados
refinados e
industrializados musculação e sono
adequado Ok
e o uso do clomifeno né o c que é o
modulador seletivo de estrogênio né isso
vai ajudar como eu falei anteriormente
para aumentar a testosterona endógena se
o testículo ainda funciona a própria
reposição hormonal com testosterona com
gdmo implante ou injeção e os
suplementos que eu já comentei
aqui não sei se será isso tu queria
saber tá blandon se você tiver ao vivo
me diga aí se foi o suficiente essa
resposta
eh ah você tá sim você tá aí ao vivo aí
você me responde se foi suficiente então
boa
noite acho que eu não falei boa noite
paraa Cristina ainda Boa noite Cristina
boa noite
Sandra próxima
pergunta Minha esposa está em tratamento
com radioterapia quimi oral
temozolomida 100 200 mg apesar dos
tratamentos ela tem tido poucos efeitos
colaterais aind está frágil um pouco
nauseada e sem equilíbrio tenho mantido
vitamina D 10.000 diários Magnésio e
vitamina C bem gente tem umas duas
perguntas aqui que estão muito próximo
de uma espécie de consulta informal
vocês sabem que eu não gosto disso mas
eu vou fazer o meu melhor para responder
de uma maneira que não pareça ser uma
consulta Ok então no caso aqui eu me
sensibilizei pelo caso né do Álvaro que
a esposa tá passando por
quimioterapia e
radioterapia vamos ver se eu consigo
ajudar ele um pouco aqui
tá na verdade é menos uma pergunta e
mais uma afirmação né ah não tem uma
parte acho que tem uma parte aqui que eu
que eu não li aqui pera aí deixa eu aar
acho que tá para trás aqui aqui ó
pergunto Há algum suplemento ou vitamina
que seja indicado para que ela cinta
melhor é muito genérico essa pergunta
tá tentar ajudar aqui
bem você já tá dando vitamina D Magnésio
e vitamina C já vai
ajudar em termo de náusea o gengibre
ajuda você pode usar em cápsula o chá
fresco a Glutamina eu sei que no câncer
muita gente viu o material do L Ribeiro
que fala muito contra a Glutamina e tem
outros profissionais e médicos e
pesquisadores que falam que Glutamina
ela alimenta o
câncer Eu acho um pouco complicado and
ter vendo material um vídeo recentemente
sobre isso é porque Glutamina é o mino
ácido mais abundante
da alimentação né bem Algumas pessoas
dizem de usar Glutamina para ajudar a
proteger a mucosa intestinal mas se você
acredita que a Glutamina pode estimular
o câncer Eu não eu acho isso uma coisa
meio
complicada você pode não utilizar
Glutamina
Ok mas ela pode ajudar a reduzir
desconfortos digestivos ômega3 seria uma
opção também
interessante probióticos de alta
qualidade vão contribuir para S
intestinal e para síntese de vitaminas a
nível
intestinal você pode estar usando
coenzima q10 200 mg por dia o nac que eu
já comentei em outro em outra pergunta
né 600 GR por
dia Porém você tem que evitar os
suplementos antioxidantes sem excesso
durante a radioterapia que pode
atrapalhar pode interferir no mecanismo
de ação tanto da Kim quanto da rádio tem
gente tem uma dieta antiinflamatória com
alimentos integrais proteínas magras
gorduras boas com abacate Castanha
azeite de oliva
hidratação atividade física leve Tá bom
mais do que isso teria que ser uma
consulta
ou você passar com oncologista tipo o
Felipe ou Gustavo Vilela para ser uma
coisa mais personalizada
tá e meus sentimentos aí Torço muito
para que tudo dê certo
tá próxima
pergunta da Marilda ten almoçado fora de
casa com bastante frequência assim
muitas vezes quando percebo já ingeri
glúten são empanados bolinhos
etc coisas que em casa não faço tenho
carregado comigo glut digest da pergunto
para ingestões Pequenas de
glutem mais talvez de áreas ele é
eficiente eu não contaria com ele para
ingestão diária
tá esse GL digestal
ele tem enzimas como é o caso da dpp4
que vai ajudar a quebrar as proteínas
gliadina e glutenina e vai reduzir a
carga que chega no
intestino porém é importante que você
entenda que nenhum suplemento desses
elimina 100% dos efeitos do
glúten se você for muito sensível tá ou
mesmo se você for
celíaco então ele não é 100% eficaz
agora se você tá comendo empanado ou
bolinho quase que diário aí não vai
funcionar tão bem o risco de reação vai
continuar existindo
é melhor que você consiga ter uma
abstinência
maior tentar se planejar melhor aí
quanto à refeições fora de
casa mas você pode usar sim o glúten
digest para situações de urgência
Tá mas cuidado porque ele não é tão
eficiente assim como você possa
pensar tentar reduzir o máximo possível
consumo pergunta do
huberg Olá Dr Alan eu comprei Aquele
suplemento que tem os
bacteriófagos esperando chegar eu tenho
um
desequilíbrio de bactéria Grand
negativas com predomínio Espero poder me
ajudar na disbiose outro problema é
minha homoc steina 24 que não baixa
mesmo suplementando com metilfolato
predox CIC fosfato metil Colina perdão
trimetil glicina e Colina a minha B12
normalmente deve tá querendo dizer que a
B12 é normal não tem insf renal crônica
investiguei aqui descobri que tenho
vários problemas na reciclagem da sist
que está deixando travada e não baixa
são as minhas enzimas envolvidas na
metilação que tem a eficiência reduzida
e caus disbiose polimorfismo do Gene nod
2 fut 2 mais hiperhomocisteinemia
é o herer rubert ele tá ao vivo sim ele
tá ao
vivo pergunta o que posso fazer para
melhorar a eficiência enzimática dessas
enzimas com polimorfismo você tem algum
fator que promova melhor atividade
enzimática no corpo na minha experiência
suplementando arginina aspartato
ornitina serina e bioms melhoram a minha
metilação e pioram com valina dieta
cetogênica e probiótico estou um pouco
perdido aqui no que fazer precisando de
ajuda a tua pergunta é bem complexa vou
tentar ajudar da melhor forma tá bem
começando aí pela homocisteina elevada
você falou que tem polimorfismos
genéticos mthfr
shmt
bhmt e
CBS são enzimas envolvidas aí na
metilação
e mesmo suplementando o metilfolato
perox 5 fosfato kb6 ativa o trimiti
glicina e Colina não tá baixando a m
cisteína vamos falar dos cofatores
específicos que podem ativar essas vias
que você falou aí no caso do mthfr que é
metilen tetrahidrofolato redutase além
do metilfolato tem a riboflavina não sei
tá usando que a
B2 ela otimiza essa enzima Então é bom
você dar uma olhada nos níveis de B2 ou
começar repor B2 né que é a
que atua nessa
via aparentemente você tá usando já aina
né que serina vira glicina glicina vira
serina você tá usando a serina Deixa eu
confirmar
aqui não tenho certeza mas se você não
tiver usando a cerina Seria uma boa usar
a cerina tá ou a glicina na verdade
trimetil glicina já tem glicina então
ela vira serina
Então você já usa porque você tá usando
trimetilglicina e tá usando também a
peridal 5 fosfato então além desses dois
aí que você tá usando a CBS a Sta Bet
sintase ela também Depende de
molibidênio que é o mineral elementar
traço e a B3 que a niacina tá então
tenta usar o molibidênio e a niacina já
vou falar as doses tá já o bhmt
você pode manter a suplementação contra
metil glicina em colina Que são fontes
de grupo metil mas verifique se você não
tem deficiência de zinco que também a
bhmt Depende de zinco
tá você comentou aqui
também que tem o polimorfismo CBS
né que é estaa Beta
sintase esses casos pode ter excesso de
amônia no organismo então a ornitina
esse aminoácido ornitina e a arginina
eles ajudam no ciclo da ureia Ok então
você tem que evitar excesso de proteína
animal excesso de alimentos ricos em
chofre para poder dar suporte também
para essa
enzima agora no caso complexo como seu
eu sugiro que você faça exam de ácidos
orgânicos urinários tá para poder ver
com detalhes essas vias
bioquímicas falando sobre a disbiose que
tá relacionada à aquele genes nod do e
fut 2is os bacteriófagos eles podem
ajudar a reduzir as bactérias Gran
negativas porém é importante você
reforçar a barreira intestinal com
Glutamina zinco carnosina e butirato tá
que é o ácido butírico ele pode ser
encontrado por exemplo no amido
resistente como é o caso da banana verde
os probióticos os lactobacilos reuter e
bif do bacterium também pode ser uma boa
opção aí para
disbiose então não faça a dieta
cetogênica que você comentou que pioram
os seus sintomas porque aumenta a
produção de
amônia Procure utilizar carboidratos
complexos por causa da do butirato e
também
para ajudar na questão aí
de aumentar as fibras do intestino né
para as bactérias a batata doce a
mandioca então resumindo vitamina B2
zinco e molibidênio pode ser
interessante isir pro sua homocisteina
alta fazer o exame de ácidos orgânicos
urinários para ter vários lugares que
chamam isso de teste metabolômica outros
lugares chamam isso de
nutrev Tá mas o nome mais genérico É
ácidos orgânicos urinários tá
usa a vitamina B2 em doses altas 200 a
400 mg por dia usa o molibidenio de 50 a
100 mg por dia verifica o seu zinco
pensa em utilizar de 15 a 30 mg por dia
com acompamento médico
tá cuida do intestino como eu já
falei você tá usando n eu não lembro se
acho que na você não tá usando na também
baixa cisteína tá Seria uma boa você
usar o na também
Ok procurei ajudar aqui mas é um caso
muito complexo e praticamente também
aquela situação que a gente fala né É
quase que tentando pegar uma consulta né
mas eu resolvi responder aqui
porque para quem gosta de bioquímica que
é um caso interessante né Eu acho que
vocês não entenderam metade do que eu
falei né mas eu tô tentando acompanhar a
pergunta que foi complexa Tá mas estô
disponível aí para tirar dúvidas se
vocês
quiserem esclarecer alguma coisa aí do
que eu falei minha próxima pergunta do
Alexandre Existe algum suplemento que
remova micropartículas de plástico do
organismo tá aí a pergunta de 5 Bilhões
de Dólares viu não existe ainda nenhum
suplemento que faça isso isso aí na
verdade é uma das coisas mais
preocupantes do
momento é uma informação muito nova
dessas micropartículas de plástico que
estão sendo encontradas em cérebro em
parede de artéria em coração para tudo
quanto é lado e eu não conheço nada que
seja muito eficiente contra isso você
pode fazer é melhorar os mecanismos de
detox do organismo mas na garantia que
vai tirar microplástico não não
é se você consumir algumas fibras
solúveis como é o caso do psí ou goma de
Acácia isso ajuda a nível intestinal a
capturar toxinas mas não vai tirar os
plásticos já
entraram mesma coisa com clorela pode
ajudar a não
entrar mas tirar o microplástico que já
entrou não conheço nada
viu a única coisa que você pode fazer é
tentar eliminar o plástico da sua vida
né tentar é bem difíc n fazer isso hoje
em dia já é difícil convencer as pessoas
a não esquentar no micro-ondas o
plástico ou guardar coisa na geladeira
no tuperware da vida agora falar para
não usar plástico em nenhum momento não
usar garrafa de água de
plástico é bem complicado
isso bem tomara que nos próximos meses
ou anos a gente tenha mais informações
aí úteis para ajudar porque a tua
pergunta é a pergunta de 5 milhões de
dólares 5 Bilhões de Dólares na verdade
orora tem umas perguntas do Eliseu aqui
Eliseu é o seguinte você tá Deixa
explicar para você o negócio aqui você
mandou um vídeo
mostrando uma gravação de células de
defesa atuando em vitro tá que elas
estão em meio de
Cultura essas perguntas que fez aqui não
se aplicam porque você tá querendo falar
de uma coisa que acontece nosso
organismo utilizando um vídeo que é de
células de defesa atuando em vitro Tá
então não tem essa história de
suplemento que vai aumentar a velocidade
do glóbulo branco porque você tá
utilizando uma premissa errada tá é um
vídeo mostrando uma mafic atuando dentro
de uma placa de Petre dentro de um
laboratório tá isso não é em vivo isso é
inv vitro Tá então não adianta você
tentar buscar suplementos para aumentar
a velocidade de glóbulo branco com
eh essas coisas aqui que você tá
colocando aqui
tá mesma coisa outra pergunta que você
fez aqui
ó tá at uma pergunta aqui negócio aqui ó
ã no outro vídeo diz que essas guerras
entre Soldados do bem e bactérias
acontec o tempo todo sim acontece o
tempo todo tá esse tá perguntando eu
posso responder que sim
tá aí tem uma outra pergunta sua aqui se
você machucou a perna começou a sangrar
e não tomou vacina antitetânica não tem
suplemento que substitua a vacina
antitetânica
viu não tem tá então se você se cortou
com uma coisa inf
ferrujada alguma coisa suspeita tome a
vacina antitetânica tá isso aqui é uma
exceção suponha também que me receitaram
antibiótico amoxacilina com clavulanato
e não comprei considerando que o
objetivo desse antibiótico é matar
bactérias wins os primos que
substituiriam não tem um substituto
direto aí vai depender se se o ferimento
infectou você vai ter que tomar
antibiótico não tem jeito agora se o
ferimento não tá infectado não
necessariamente você obrigado a tomar
antibiótico tá
Tod suplementos aqui que você tá
colocando são mais preventivos tá não é
para tratar infecção ativa eu não
recomendo tá Se tiver infecção di ferida
tem que tomar ó mesmo não tem jeito
ou arriscar né É lógico que o própolis
Verde vai ajudar o vitamina D vai ajudar
mas não é razoável você pensar que vão
substituir o antibiótico por uma ferida
infectada tá mais que eu gost de
medicina natural eu também não vou
propor nada que coloque vocês em risco
Ok tem mais uma pergunta aqui do Eliseu
na embalagem do suplemento gar Oil daal
Foods diz na parte da frente 1500 MG mas
na parte de trás diz amount Pering que
seria quantidade
por dose né serving seria mais ou menos
do garlic Oil concentrate Altivo bu 9 m
equivalente a 4500 do
rov garlic eu acho melhor dar uma olhada
nesse suplemento aqui para ver o que que
você táa falando aqui eu vou abrir a
página aqui do
suplemento vamos
lá tá Já já achei aqui vamos tentar
acompanhar sua
pergunta não menciona percentual de Ina
Não não é porque tá não tá falando do
percentual de alicina não quer dizer que
é suspeito não
tá eu tô vendo aqui o que o que você
comentou é que assim esse 1500 MG é o
óleo Total tá é o óleo que tá dentro da
cápsula 1500
MG e esse gark Oil Concept
ST al sativo Bob equivalente a 4500 de
rol clove
garlic É que na verdade eh são três soft
gels que é o
serving é o serving né na verdade ele
pede para tomar três né Cada um tem 1500
MG do Óleo tá E então por isso dá
4500 na hora que seja junto os três as
três soft gels
tá E aí vai ter 9 MG do precativo por
isso que tá falando 9 MG aqui no no no
verso mas ele não comenta nada de
alicina não
aqui
tá porque isso aqui na verdade não é um
suplemento específico de alicina que
você tá vendo
aqui não é suspeito tá então a dose
depende eh se você tá falando de
princípio ativo é 9 MG se você tá
falando do Óleo inteiro é 1500 MG por
soft Gel
tá
ah ainda sobre o plástico a pergunta do
Alexandre tem alguma forma
exame para medir a contaminação do
organismo não não tem Infelizmente não
tem esse exame no laboratório da Esquina
né esses estudos estão sendo feito com
microplásticos estão usando técnicas
avançadas tá estão utilizando
espectrometria de massa para identificar
as partículas em amostr de sangue esses
exames não estão disponíveis ainda para
o público em geral em laboratórios
clínicos
Ok dá para você ver de uma maneira
indireta em alguns laboratórios por um
marcador chamado malon de aldeído tá
malon de aldeído que é
ida também não é todos os laboratórios
que tem esse marcador
Respondendo a sua
pergunta essa foi a última tem algumas
pessoas falando aqui o Álvaro comentando
Muito obrigado vou seguir as suas
recomendações de
nada o blandon dizendo que as perguntas
foram esclarecidas obrigado blandon
então a cicolina e o alfa GPC eles são
formas de acetilcolina mais avançadas
tá essa tua pergunta é boa se vale a
pena usar os dois eu sinceramente acho
que não Ó o alfa GPC mais caro que o
citicolina que também não é barato eu
utilizaria um ou outro os dois juntos
Acho que não não tem vantagem não viu
Isaac Não não é o único PRP ativo da do
tem milhares de substância Eliseu não é
só alicina não a gente usa alicina mais
para tratamento aí de cibo né mas tem
vários outros princípios
ativos partir de qual percentual de
alicina o suplemento é excelente Boa
pergunta não tenho um número na minha
cabeça agora não vou ver se eu acho isso
para você agora aqui
um momento só
pelo que eu tô vendo 1% já é um um
considerado excelente tá 1% viu
Eliseu de nada
Alexandre sim Eliseu para fins de
tratamento de cibo sim tá tá estamos
falando aqui da questão do cí agora
existe o óleo negro que a funcionalidade
dele é para prevenção de doença
cardiovascular e paraa redução do
colesterol tem tem um suplemento
americano bom mas ele é
caro eu vou eu vou achar ele aqui porque
tem muito tempo que eu não mexo com esse
suplemento
que ela é difícil de
importar mas já te respondo só um
minutinho
Ah sim é já achei
aqui chama Alice Max
tá também tem um outro da met
que tem chama Cand
BR esse também tem alicina em alta
concentração
tá então alic
Max tinha um ALX também se eu não me
engano tinha chamado alimax agora eu
lembrei isso alimax pro 450 mg É esse
mesmo deixa eu colocar ele na tela aqui
ó aqui ó esse aqui ó alimax pro Esse é
um dos melhores produtos que tem com
alicina tá bom al Max pro
é def eventado
sim bem pessoal eu vou encerrar por
agora eu tinha uns artigos para discutir
com vocês mas hoje a gente acabou
ficando muito tempo no nas perguntas eu
vou deixar pra semana que vem eu acabei
atrasando um pouco para começar a Live
que eu tava com uma questão pessoal aqui
mas semana que vem a gente discute os
artigos tá bom
Obrigado aí pela presença de
vocês vou responder só sua última
pergunta aqui ô
Eliseu cozedor de ovos
elétricos mata salmonela a partir de
quantos minutos não sei tem
que checar o fabricante tá não conhece
produto de nada Sandra de nada essa
parte que eu falei aí do da metilação
acho que foi muito complicado foi muito
técnico mas é que a pergunta foi muito
técnica também viu então peço perdão a
vocês se ficou
confuso sim eu tinha um professor no
primário que ele fazia isso ele comia
alho para caramba quando ele tinha algun
toma
de tá pegando alguma infecção o problema
é o hálito que fica né Mas ajuda
bastante sim e sim tem que ser al
Curu Obrigado Sandra obrigado por ter
gostado né apesar de ser negócio muito
pesado até para profissional de
saúde bem pessoal um abraço para vocês
até a próxima semana fique com
Deus n